forget too you have teenage boss
the abc tv show you write books it's not
as if there's only one thing that you do
i'm happy to say we're already getting
some questions
in um so we sort of answered the
question about your life
well no this is quite a direct question
from renee
so if uh if you weren't a maths teacher
so it's a
bit similar to what i've just asked you
but i don't know do you harbor
a secret desire you know that um maybe
you'd like to share with us here we
won't tell
oh yeah no obviously i mean this is
quite private but
i think i got two thoughts in my mind
the first one is
sort of this childhood dream i had um
that i wanted to be a firefighter
growing up um and i just thought like
it's such a heroic thing to do
and you know you can help you know
communities it's it's it's so wonderful
i then learned i mentioned uh briefly
before that i had some health issues
when i was younger
one of them is that i'm a chronic
asthmatic i'm better at managing it now
but it's still an issue
and so i learned that you know what
being a firefighter and frequently going
into places filled with smoke
not the greatest profession for someone
with asthma like mine
uh so that's maybe a bit of a frivolous
thing to say uh honestly
the thing that i would love most to do
if i weren't a teacher
um is to be a stay-at-home dad
my my kids like i just constantly think
about
um the privilege it is to to raise
young children not so young children now
um to be able to give them
love an environment where they know
they're cared for
where they know that there are people in
their lives who believe in them
and will support them to do whatever it
is
that they can do to serve their
communities and grow and flourish in
themselves
what a joy that is and i constantly feel
like
that's the theme that i would want to
spend more time doing if i weren't doing
all the rest of the things great
eddie what do you struggle with
hmm i think i struggle with a
how much time do you say we have jane um
i
i struggle with so many things um
probably uh
one of the biggest ones that i struggle
with is kind of this uh
undercurrent of guilt i guess around all
of the things that i don't do
i feel in a wonderful wonderfully
privileged position
that i get the opportunity to do lots of
different things
but whenever i i think about all the
things i
i could do i think about the things that
i don't um so as a really
you know obvious example there are 2
215 schools in um
in public schools i should say in new
south wales and i've
probably worked directly with
about a quarter of them um which
sounds like a lot in one sense it's like
500 schools that's that's a fair few
but at the same time it's kind of like
wow 75 percent of the state i haven't
even begun to
touch because i'm one human being and
there's only so much that a single
person can do
i already mentioned the time that i
would love to spend i could there's kind
of this bottomless pit of things i would
love to do
with my family and i struggle with that
and i struggle with sometimes the
paralyzing feeling that that gives me of
i can't do all of it should i even
bother with any of it
and sometimes i go into little valleys
of that
particularly when life and work are hard
so that's i think an over
an overarching struggle that i've had
all the way through my life
thank you vicky has asked what was the
kindness
or support that you received
some time from someone unexpected and
how did that change your life that's a
great question vicki
wow that's um that's a big one um look
yeah i think
i'm thinking of a bunch of different
people and i
couldn't pick out just one um because
this one it wouldn't be fair
to the range of people who've done this
to me but i often think
uh you know i mentioned before that i'm
a classic introvert but
as a teacher you kind of have to learn a
lot of traditionally
extroverted skills like communication
and forming relationships with people
developing rapport and that kind of
thing and so i guess what sort of comes
along with that territory
and i think this is something that we
all do in you know ways shapes and forms
is you kind of develop a bit of a
persona
like you kind of put on a suit and this
is who i am in front of other people
um and you kind of have different suits
and personas for different groups of
people you interact with
one of the things which i think i
learned from a young age
when i experienced bullying like you
mentioned from primary school
is that there are certain places or
groups of people where if you are
vulnerable
with them you will end up really hurt
and it's not a nice thing to reckon with
but it's also reality
and so i think from that early age i
thought you know my coping mechanism i
guess was to hide
um to think about my real deep inner
personality and to say that's not
something
that i want to be necessarily out there
in the open because that will be
ridiculed and it will be you know
attacked and hated
and so i think where i've experienced
those
surprising kindnesses that uh is what
the question was about
is all those many times that so many
people throughout my life
have found out have have sort of
discovered me and got to know me better
and instead of pulling away um and
and being sort of shocked or not wanting
to know me it's like you know what
that's fine
actually have known and appreciated me
more
that's a really special experience and
i'm very grateful that that's happened a
number of times
to me so for all of those people who've
let me see
that part of myself that actually can be
loved and valued
yeah there's nothing else i can say
except thank you
well that's a wonderful insight eddie
thank you for that
i'm sorry if i've said that wrong has
said you're
uh inspirational and you set a great
example
do you have any specific methods to
encourage
the kids you teach to be kinder
wow that's a that's a delightful
question i think um
i think the biggest thing that always
comes to the front of my mind
is i always want my students to
recognize the impact that they have
on other people i think that this is uh
actually something that harks back to
this is a really strange connection to
make but
i'm a mathematics teacher and these are
the things whizzing around in my mind
i don't know if jane the phrase the
butterfly effect
is something you've ever heard of it's
an idea in mathematics and physics which
is that sometimes in some situations
a very small tweak in one spot
can actually have enormous effects
elsewhere so the butterfly effect is
named after
a butterfly flapping its wings on one
side of the ocean
and that little current of air just
grows and grows and grows into a mighty
wind and becomes a typhoon
on the other side of the ocean now that
sounds like a fairly negative way to say
it
but i think and this is what i try to
encourage my students to do
i think we can think of that positively
as well the smallest
acts of kindness can sometimes have
really profound effects
on the people around us and i feel very
thankful that
a number of times my ex students have
returned back to school to say hello
they've been dropping in
saying hi to all of their past teachers
and sometimes
they'll relay to me a story of some
interaction i had with them that made
some very deep impression
on them and often i'm gonna say nine
times out of ten
it's an interaction or a conversation i
don't remember
and it's not just because i have a bad
memory i promise
it's sometimes the smallest things a
conversation i had with a student just
as the bell went
and we walked out of that class together
out to lunch and
instead of me you know just making a
beeline for the staff room i actually
happened to walk with this student to
wherever he or she was having lunch with
their friends and i just had that
conversation with them over a couple of
minutes
that was such a small thing i do that
all the time because it feels natural
to spend this very you know precious
time with these students
trying to encourage them and give them a
positive influence but
to know that that can have a very deep
and lasting effect on someone
that's pretty special and i always want
my students to take that lesson away
from their time at school
wow eddie thank you we have
about six minutes left to go and
jane asks not this one um
do you think that kindness solves most
problems encountered in the classroom
and playground and possibly the world or
is that stretching it too much
um i i'm an optimist so i can definitely
come alongside the idea that kindness
especially
undeserved kindness like when i was
talking about forgiveness before
it is powerful and it can have really
deep
and amazing effects not just on an
individual but indeed on a whole class a
school
a society i do want to recognize though
that sometimes the problems that we face
around us
to reckon with their reality um
a simple kind act sometimes isn't enough
and i don't want us to
you know imagine that some of the
systemic problems around us
can simply be solved by one act here or
another i think for example
and that the fact that i often work with
regional schools across new south wales
and in rural and remote settings
sometimes the challenges that
communities face out there
are far deeper and run further into a
community's
past its history they're far more
profound than can simply be undone
by a few individual acts here and there
we have to reckon
with the fabric of society the history
that's brought us here
um and the things that have been done
that we need to reckon with i mean it
was recently nadoc week and i think
about
um when the national when the apology to
the stolen generations was given
that was a powerful marker and
it was a start of a conversation but
that in itself
was not enough it's just a symbol right
so i guess i want to recognize
the impact of kindness but also uh want
to wrestle with the fact that
sometimes we have to be thoughtful and
creative and determined in how we
show that kindness not just individual
acts but across our entire
culture and society